quel serait votre rêve de bonheur kendji
Girac avec je crois 60 personnes autour
de vous vous êtes le tonton de 10 à 12
neveux et nièces c'est le rêve d'une
famille nombreuse vous aussi votre
propre famille nombreuse alors oui c'est
sûr j'aimerais bien avoir une famille
nombreuse c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai qu'avec le temps qui
court c'est à réfléchir quand même 3 5 6
3 5 6 bon je dirais quatre allez vas-y
récap comme comme vous savez comme une
table il faut les quatre pieds pour la
tenir effectivement l'équilibre
l'équilibre donc je pense que quatre
c'est bien cette grande chanson de de
cet album que j'adore et le jour où j'ai
commencé à la faire en studio j'ai
ça m'a ému vraiment vraiment beaucoup
parce que j'étais très très fier de
pouvoir chanter avec Florent Pagny j'ai
un longtemps que j'attendais ce duo et
donc Florent il allait mieux quand je
lui ai proposé de venir chanter sur cet
album déjà j'étais très très content
pour lui
je l'ai invité en studio il était aussi
pris content de chanter parce que ça
faisait un petit moment qu'il avait plus
rechanter une des premières fois
effectivement qu'il recommence à chanter
après ces traitements contre le cancer
exactement donc après il est revenu pour
lui c'était un peu la découverte il m'a
dit qu'est-ce que je verrai entendre ma
voix je sais pas qu'est-ce que ça fait
depuis
je crois qu'il m'avait dit ah non ça
faisait un an qu'il avait pu rechanter
du tout plus aucune note du coup il a il
voulait redécouvrir sa voix quoi dans ce
studio donc tout ça c'était c'était
énorme de vivre ce moment-là avec avec
Florent comment il va vous avez de ses
nouvelles vous communiquez beaucoup oui
ça va on s'écrit on s'écrit pas mal et
là il est il est sera mieux il va
beaucoup mieux et je pense qu'il profite
un peu au soleil chez lui un Argentine
bah oui là actuellement il est là-bas et
on attend son retour avec impatience
aussi c'est évidemment cette chanson
Bella mais version alors c'est Gims mais
ces versions kendji qui nous emballe qui
nous emportent tous cette chanson vous
dites merci encore et encore
ah oui oui je remercie de toute façon
cette chanson j'ai déjà remercier Gims
aussi l'autre jour Mika parce que c'est
vrai qu'elle m'a amené très très loin
en plus les réseaux sociaux commençait à
grandir de plus en plus et je voulais
avoir quelques j'aime pour pour voilà
pour que tout le monde like des photos
et tout donc je faisais plein de sport
je mettais des photos de moi torse nu
j'ai essayé d'attirer l'attention au
maximum et
sauf qu'un jour je buvais le café avec
mon oncle et il m'avait entendu chanter
cette chanson de loin il me dit kendji
je crois que bien entendu chantilly un
morceau de rap à la guitare c'est rare
personne a fait ça je dis bah ouais
ouais je me débrouille juste une chanson
de maître Gims et j'ai écouté l'album en
boucle en plus de Gims à l'époque toutes
l'été on avait que cet album et on se
régalait avec les cousins on était en
vélo en mode stranger things
et du coup
m'a demandé de la chanter donc je l'ai
refait j'ai chanté la chanson il me dit
mais la sur Facebook comme ça on va voir
combien j'aime tu vas voir et moi je dis
ah c'est une bonne idée pour avoir des
j'aime je dis allons-y et là je chante
la chanson et je la mets sur Internet et
là c'est là où tout a commencé c'est
champion Kenji évidemment c'est cette
fiction téléfilm sur l'illetterie dans
lequel vous jouez Zac je ne menuisier
qui cache qu'il ne s'est ni lire ni
écrire jusqu'au jour bah il se retrouve
face à ses lacunes il doit gérer en fait
l'entreprise de menuiserie familiale
faut savoir qu'en France 7% de la
population est idérée
c'est énorme alors il y a plusieurs
choses chez vous c'est que c'est de
votre première fois en tant qu'acteur et
puis c'est un sujet aussi quand même oui
c'est un sujet qui est très très
important
parce que j'imagine que c'est très très
compliqué et moi avant j'ai eu des
difficultés d'écriture parce que je
faisais beaucoup de fautes j'ai parce
que maintenant le stylo la feuille on
écrit presque jamais
[Musique]
ce sont paramidiose
merci kendji on a voyagé avec vous merci
beaucoup c'est ce cinquième album studio
l'école de la vie bien sûr avec tous ces
titres que vous nous faites découvrir en
aparté